and we know somebody that's been
involved in embankments better than
anybody I mean we talk about the
Christopher Columbus of embankments and
and that's our man Billy conforto our IP
and right now we got a special moment
actually I'm gonna call his brother
Chuckie and get him on the line right
here and this is uh Chuckie hello what
up Chuck
what's up oh I'm doing good man how are
you I'm doing okay man I was just over
in Biloxi at the casino over there doing
um a show this past weekend so you know
I had off at my brother's house Saturday
we had a live fantasy football draft
yesterday actually he come back and he
was like man that's hilarious
well next time when I come over to the
to Louisiana I'll get you over to one
yeah be great man uh dude there's so
many fans that are that are fans of
Billy brah yeah yeah so many people love
him man um you know and I just wanted to
know like a little bit more about him
because you know I met him we used to be
was Busboys together and uh and he was
probably the wildest dude I've ever met
in my life man you know I was I was
talking to my brother young she had
seven kids in eight years which a lot of
people have a lot of kids Jesus that's
like Drew Brees type numbers bro when
you we have a bunch of baby daddies or
whatever I say yeah I was telling us
how's that my younger brother's house uh
when I was texting you I think yesterday
he was like oh so like 3 o'clock in the
morning I was playing cornhole and my
days all mixed up here but anyway
we was talking it was like this is like
handbilling he goes mom your mom always
sending us to the store and running back
and forth and Billy came over one day I
got your bike errands I got your bike he
was wild man yeah he was one of a kind
did he I mean I don't yeah he and I were
bus but well I guess he was a waiter at
this restaurant and then next thing I
know dude he was always he had us always
on like all kind of weed adventures he
was doing he was running weed he was
always getting his car fixed he even
give you salt on that a little bit
together with you know with with the
dude I remember we was working at the
restaurant and then yeah dude I remember
I used to drive him across the lake to
get weed and we would come back with so
much weed brah well the person he was
coming to oh there we go yeah well look
nice too nice to talk to you again man
dude and y'all had the craziest [ __ ]
family people was box and people was uh
I mean people were that people wrong
pills everything was going on yeah
drugs did run the toss only apart you
know it was Billy then three cousins we
took and you know your boys could box I
mean they were good they were gone
somewhere but that monkey got on and
they couldn't get it off so it was tough
I'm you know it's what do you do you
know they don't want to be that way talk
to Billy about it all the time Billy
would get me through getting these moves
where you know he wouldn't see him for a
while and we all knew what he was gone
but then he would show up Billy again
get the camera out he always had this
Polaroid camera you could pull it out
and he would take a picture and he was
like I'm holding onto the picture and
we're gonna tell you know so yes going
pictures right so then we would go work
out hard
he wouldn't let you uh you couldn't skip
you couldn't cut a rep short he was on
you
that's how Billy was and even like I
heard when you cast about the steroids
he said that I had a flashback god I
used to be like that I remember like he
was he's doing to think like winch cross
something crazy and yeah and I kind of
like man I'm playing football I want to
try that too so it's gonna be the
routine this is how we're gonna write it
all up just crazy like a mad scientist
he was like so he would tell you we
gotta take it a half hour before we work
out and when you said that I remember
distinctly a half hour before the gym
pull over my boy listen wait so let's go
to apartment a something your partner's
around the corner from the gym no we got
start right now and doing we actually
it's not that happened then we did it
overall for the interstate over but
between Slidell and uh the exit bought a
movie theater brought we would duck off
over there [ __ ] pipe him down boy
dude Billy was so he was so goofy bro he
would yeah he was so like I forgot about
how much we used to go to the gym and
that was the big thing we would go to
the gym do to protein shakes like he was
on it yeah he was when he was working on
I mean Billy wasn't a big dude but that
boy kept - Brian he was nothing fighting
doing and he was he was a he was tough -
dude he was a toughest material so well
I cut you off now go on so my wife and I
we walking down Bourbon Street one day I
look down the side street and I see
these three dudes on this one dude
giving it torn but this dude is giving
it back I mean he's some help fighting
this one dude man my wife's just looking
and look I'm like holy [ __ ] that's my
brother and I
we're trying to get away like my
frightened back knock one down it would
start to run up and he trying to run
away but he just didn't wanted to get
you know that means he's going after him
steadily he always everything because
I'm like man dude he was like yeah he
was like a million people trapped in one
person you right that's a good analogy
of him right he was so many friends a
lot of people get like he was a likable
you oh but he was the most likable
brother when he came to Mandeville I
mean everybody liked a man I mean
everybody he was like the mayor man it
was like you know he was just I don't
know man he was just so [ __ ]
ridiculous and but he would give you the
shirt off his back man in a million
times he like he would do things for
people that you would just never expect
that man and he I felt like he was like
loyal just an insane level you know dad
that's Billy that's Billy yep definitely
was that in the dogs now this this [ __ ]
that scare me about his whole [ __ ]
family bran y'all got attack animals
Const y'all had so many [ __ ] attack
animals dude no pull up to Billy's house
if he would have a pit bull on the roof
like I'm gonna push them off the couch
and the dog brawl daddy
it was a trip dude he was that he was a
trip man
he only shows up one time I'm I'm at my
mom's house I don't remember there might
have been a birthday or Mother's Day and
we're late you know each other let me
head I'm gonna try ugf FaceTime audio
can I call you on FaceTime audio do you
ever heard that yep
let me call you on that right now okay
all right yo yeah I can hear you
it's way better now way but you know
what I probably should have turned off
no everything is great man I appreciate
it look dude I just appreciate even just
having this conversation man even just
being able to think about your brother
man you know I was at a time in my life
when I met him that you know I just
needed I think I needed like a friend my
brother had kind of gotten into drugs at
the time and or my brother just wasn't
him out my brother wasn't in my life at
the time and so Billy was just he was
just cool you know he was just kind of
everything he was you're loyal he was
caring he was like he was almost like a
whole family stuck in one [ __ ] little
Italian dude that was losing his hair
you know yeah like you know when my son
you know I text you a little bit about
my son actually stumbled across your
podcast and uh I you know walked past
his lil he's in his room he's like I'm
like I know that dude used to be uncle's
friend and I told him a little bit about
chin and and that's when I tweeted you
and the shirts and all sup my son well
as his it seems like every other days
got it on and he doesn't remember my
brother as much died son just had been 6
or 7 years old at the time I guess yeah
he's been due years he has got to see my
son box girl oh your son boxes oh oh
well it doesn't anymore he's got a bunch
of amateur fights we tried to qualify
for Olympics the last ones that they had
way back when he got to like a semifinal
but muscle I love my brother
hilarious it's crazy with so much
yeah man Billy was hell dude that was
the thing it was like he can teach you
to fight he could teach you to [ __ ]
cook but we got so high one night and uh
and first of all he had those pit bulls
dude I couldn't get high and be around a
pit bull but I was so scared the dogs it
really would be like do bruh what's
wrong with you bro if I dude I'm [ __ ]
high as [ __ ] and his dog brother I could
kill both of us right Billy
he had those dog eyes I don't know how
he did it when he passed your we were
all like what are we gonna do with his
dogs and I remember we all was afraid of
and so there's no bill I used to say
goes when I die I put my dogs in a
coffin with but you know so when he when
he dead pass everybody's like what we
gonna doing his dog those dogs to the
SPCA I'm like we're gonna have to take
my wife to she was like kind of sketchy
about it not like we taken a dog's best
decision I've ever made in my life for
me and that dog was so smart in and that
was kind of like in my heyday when I was
and that Billy was handling a lot of
stuff I mean I'm a family man mm-hmm got
this whole other job I'm doing books and
professional job and going to work every
day and I had this all other say you're
poor you grew up as poor as we grew up
you don't pass up anything that an
opportunity to make a dollar you know
what I mean right
you know so it's you know when I had the
opportunity to sell some marijuana and I
was like man my brother's counter doing
a lot of that stuff already anyway I was
like I have some money Sam I was like
come on let's make some world money so
that's how we kind of got all started
into it but when you grow up as poor as
we did it's hard to pass up all that
stuff and so when Billy's business it's
a bit it's a business that's easily
accessible when it's right there you
could get into business but all you
gotta have is just a little bit of money
up front right right Holly no capital to
get started yeah it's like easy money
fast money it's nothing easy about it
you know always say somebody's paying
you a dollar an hour it's probably
because that's what the job it's all
it's all it requires it's it's all it's
there's no justification to pay you more
than a dollar an hour right right you
selling
to marijuana you be gave a couple extra
few thousand dollars extra mouth there's
no such thing as these a lot of stress
that comes we can get in trouble and
your things do happen right not the easy
money but it was available with little
capital and like said his paws we grew
up I wasn't passing up an opportunity so
when he dies and you know I'm home and
I'm kind of living a double life I want
my wife to find out and so I was putting
up the money Billy was going all the
running back and forth and so when he
passed I was like I was already kind of
established mhm and I'm telling you I
mean I've already had the charge and you
know haven't been charged and you just
stuff yet but i'ma say it anyway I guess
if they want to come get but Billy was
running back and forth in Houston what
about three hundred pounds every single
mark Wow kind of right don't [ __ ] me yes
Billy
and then like his car broke down one
time and like I'm like Billy well yeah
I'm like we you know I thought he maybe
got popped or something because you know
you he leaves you expect him to be back
the next day at around five o'clock
we'll hear from Billy right they don't
hear from you don't hear from a train
this crazy yeah bruh he was crazy what
you loved him man just Billy like that's
how he was he shows up I was telling you
we have my mom song he's over there in
the car take off be out of him about 30
seconds down the street just call
Michelle you i'ma show y'all pickles I
break the window boy the way I'm
bringing it silent and don't make any
noise I'm like he's like come on to show
you so we walk like we cut through this
yard we are not talking we man you know
I mean we know better but it's Billy so
you're just like well let's see what
this adventures gonna be yeah we walk
out he picks up these six rushes looks
like six pebbles they got to be the
right size and gets him in his hand and
he's shaking him up like you would shake
some dice at the craft a when he walks
up to this
in stealthy and quiet I'm kind of back
on the other side you know what I mean
so the trick is he's looking back at and
he's like nari don't eat that - we're
gonna be gone I'm like okay Billy throws
these rocket hits that window and Billy
would be laughing to do Billy was so
good Ronnie
dude he would even if [ __ ] was the most
serious bruh he would also be able to
laugh at the same exact moment man yep
dude it was crazy man he uh I'm trying
to think of what else yeah dude so we
got all high one night and we went over
to his place he was living off a Florida
Street in Mandeville and you know he
cooked up some chicken cutlets or
something he was always cooking you know
and uh in any [ __ ] Princess Diana had
died bro and I didn't know who Princess
Diana was I thought it was like a dog or
something and uh and Billy's like all
sad and [ __ ] and crime Brian I'm [ __ ]
high as [ __ ] dude and I just remember
thinking like dude how did I even get
what what is even going on over here
run do we should throw a party Billy
weed I think Billy came to our [ __ ]
promise school bruh just to [ __ ] go
out and party with that said that I kind
of remember him saying didn't even see
him I was like yeah well [ __ ] that's
Billy that's what he's gonna do yeah
yeah man even though one of a kind man
yeah and then just thinking like I'm
saying this stuff about him that boy had
no felonies he had a bunch of
misdemeanors no oh yeah 100% man and so
he got pretty I didn't see him liking
some of the later in some of his like
last few years and so he got pretty
addicted at that point
no Billy was always a functional attica
the drugs just did incapacitate him they
can't do anything they just they can do
Billy was never that way whenever I
would see Billy even though he was in a
million different pieces he always seems
to do he always had he always was going
somewhere doing something I had
something working on this boy you know
in the middle of being heavily addicted
to drugs he's going to college hey guys
Billy and you know he didn't actually
die from you know the how died Billy did
run into a bunch of embankments I could
just remember picking him up before him
cool I'm stuck inside the road because
they told me that his car broke down
yeah he gave me a psalm on one time and
I [ __ ] hit an embankment brought like
no joke dude in Mandeville
he gave me a some I'd never taken one
dude and I [ __ ] the first turn I took
was straight up in to a little
embankment yeah so he was on a Friday we
was at the Katrina and we was in East
over in Long Aziz and we just heard
man's house the rapper we just finished
his house did all the inside stuff like
fencing and some other stuff so I think
I'll pack some for that house and east
over and talk to him it was shocked it
was Friday 30,000 so I don't know any
child for a couple his pay was before he
married because I was working for him at
the time you don't he was on the
construction stuff and I up on the gas
station that's what I was going gone in
the gas station and going different
books for different businesses and stuff
and so went the trainer comes I start
doing a construction we do this job and
it was it was like man some friends of
his was playing Texas Hold'em so I went
I was like hey ball to Texas we get out
there we play and I'm in Metairie I'm
all the way home and he was going to our
cousin's house in Franklinton mm-hmm you
know he calls me up on a causeway it's
about one o'clock in the morning at this
point he's like man
all in the sleep a phone sleep talk to
me on my bill you we just got paid you
got that truck like there's no sense to
fall asleep at the wheel
and run off the causeway cuz that was
typical Billy you know what I mean yeah
so I'm like I talked station or side of
the causeway they got that Shell station
oh yeah right there yep
he says I'm a pole in the park am i
right here in sleep so I'm like alright
cool
so Bob twelve o'clock I'm just waking up
sittin in the parking lot this whole
time Phillips house so I'll see you
Monday Monday morning know Billy he was
dead he was gone
oh yeah so he was always functional
addict he was another wasn't another way
I had him so bad you know that it was
that he wasn't able to still be a part
of society and you know and friends and
do things yeah man he taught me a lot
you know he was uh man he was a friend
of so many brought Kenny I mean dude
it's so funny every time I talk to
somebody who knew Billy I was around
that time and have a beautiful story
about him or something [ __ ]
absolutely ridiculous dude I remember he
had a uh he had a party a crawfish boil
one time at his house and this I think
when he was living with Jimmie and
DeSean maybe or something and um dude
and they had a family showed up and the
whole family was wearing the same adidas
track suits brought the whole family bro
and I'd never seen anything like that
the children to the both the parents
calls me up come pick him up from New
Orleans la comarca I'll pick him up he's
like in Gretna so pick him up he would
tell you like bring me back but it
wasn't like it was just Bill you know
the minister he's like I'm like he tells
you that
running back to a cab he's like go
around the back what is this doing about
to do and again I know better and he
writes better but I'm like it's Billy
and this is gonna be an adventure
right what is he about to do so he goes
and it was like the trailer from an you
know semis pulled the trailers right it
was just like an empty trailer that was
parked behind the Academy so he's a cup
to the back so he gets out my car
he runs he goes you need to trail and he
starts pulling out boxes of shoes just
back because I come on let's go get
these and sticking them underneath the
trailer you know and then like going
back he could carry as many so on a cart
no I got him with one cars
Wow needless to say just use any stoves
right around Christmas time all my
nephews and some of the other kids they
all got brand-new tennis shoes for
Christmas that's why it's hilarious
right right that was God when charity
hospital was open right knit you know
New Orleans near to him and he calls me
up again he's like come pick me up I'm
over here go pick him up and he gets in
my car literally with the IV tower bring
me to my apartment I'm like Billy I'm
like wait a minute I don't even know I
think you might been there for his past
more something you had bad asthma can't
remember one of the times he might od'd
not really sure what he let him he's for
a while to just smoke a cig right this
dude gives him a car with the whole IV
tie with the bag hanging praying across
the bridge we go to his apartment to
have like security and a nursing staff
they all outside looking for his duty
gets off the car and he just like it was
I don't know I remember he got one time
he went to jail he an hour driving New
Orleans
and I threw a oh we had a joiner not
through I was pissed or something and I
threw that [ __ ] out the window or
something and in the cop stop this man
and and I passed they let me stay I was
and they took him to jail and then let
me just stay and sleep in the car and I
remember I got back and then yeah he was
always this into something man but he
was always fun he loved to be like an
instigator of life like oh right let's
get something let's make something
exciting let's get something going bruh
he dude he took me to my first boxing
match that's back when Jimmy was but box
remember that yeah oh yeah
does he still he doesn't box him or no
he's older now Jimmy yeah
Jimmy pass all of them boys are dead
Billy Jimmy Ronnie was a year older than
me but Ronnie like brothers we grew up
together to get all the time and then
when Jimmy started boxing pretty heavily
I don't live off then you know one of us
weekend tennis match make a license on
come over the license yeah whenever you
put on boxing match you gotta have a
fighter of course and then somebody's
got to have a promoters license and you
got to have a matchmakers license but
one person can't Allen how it is these
days but at the time one person could
hold all those licenses so Jimmy people
in a spot gym play some get a promoters
license if you can me a Billy one person
get a matchmaker license and Jimmy we're
like put on his little shows and nails
are just another way to make a hustle
Wow and so yeah I went to a fight I went
to I went to at least one of them over
there in Fat City over there man those
boys you know the stories from them it's
just it's you know you my wife every
time my brother would cause you know I
would just get up I'm like I have to go
get a meal Billy more close in age we
just your opponent Wow and it was just
him and I you knows most of time just
own up it was him and I him and I yeah
and so anytime you have a card he needed
it was to have fun because his even
though he had the the chemical
dependency problem you didn't really
notice it you just you only knew it
because of the things you get in trouble
you know often yeah it's always getting
arrested if something's going on
it wasn't because something was missing
out of your house or mm-hmm
did something to you he was never those
things and so he my wife always liked
having him around my kids did oh yeah he
definitely by far my mom says she
doesn't have favors but definitely by
far was my favorite yeah man he was
remarkable bro he was a man he really
really was dude he was I just yeah man I
mean just the fact that so many people
dude I was at as in Biloxi they had two
dudes had a Billy come forward to
embankment gang shirts on that's awesome
and dude it everywhere I go somebody
yelled out the other night at the show
r.i.p Billy conforto Imbros that's
happened I'm not joking in 15 different
cities so yeah and it's funny I didn't
know that was gonna happen whenever I
started talking about you know stories
from just growing up you know I never
had any intention of that but it just
goes to show how many people you know
somehow just think that he you know just
think it's he's just still entertaining
people you know yeah just quick like
tell you a billion is Hollywood as my
mom said he was so sick that was fast
but you got a chicken I just went to
Walmart and bought this low chicken coop
because I have a friend that has eggs
I bought the slow chicken coop and I buy
five chickens to put in there well I do
construction too on the side of course
right I got the stole and I'm still
doing construction yes I Billy brother
just like you gotta stop doing
construction man I love it bro
so we bility this job it's a foreclosure
that we have to like put all the stuff
out of and there was 11 chickens anyway
well we got a nice them so I took the
chicken so now I have 19 chickens I got
a pool area I got this big pool my
backyard is nice cool air eNOS chicken
sick everywhere my kids is like my wife
wants to shoot a prom and I told her I
promise I said okay no more animal
I just had goats my goats just died
about a year ago Oh goat is be dobra go
to beautiful to little I had these two
little miniature goats and it was
[ __ ] awesome I love these logos but
they died so now we got the chickens
damn do one thing that's funny is one
time we had a party my brother and Billy
used to live together and and so they
had a party one time and we wanted
people to get there it's kind of
confusing to give directions so we put
up all these signs that said goats for
sale and you just had to follow the
signs because we don't want the cops to
know as a party so all these signs
across town said goats for sale and then
you got to Austin to the party dude it
was so funny bro yeah my brother like
did Billy was just all I don't know man
it life was exciting when he was around
man it definitely was fun and cessful
saying so growing up you know he's born
sick and you know with the hands me my
mum that's why take was a sickly kid and
so you know growing up I think he might
have been 2 or 3 years old combi
Treatise oak tree right now he got up -
remember him on my head and like go get
the ladder so he's getting down so this
is 3 4 yo can't climb this tree didn't
allow on his face that's why it's nope
really oh right twice nose was crooked
like that he fell out of a tree at 3
years old and just I'm assuming that's
why but he did definitely that's what my
mom says he broke his nose I was young I
don't remember I just remember stories
they said you know I mean yeah a tree
and broke his nose and I just remember
you know he always restored me I'm 63
he always was short she did I just
remember we would always get into these
fights you know growing up poor we lived
on the west bank in Lawrence and bad
areas and somebody was always stealing
not buying so start you couldn't walk
this far without somebody punching you
in the face and this isn't kids that's
your size fight yeah I remember we had
this Doberman that we found somewhere
and we had to stop whole time we moved
actually from one house I went to this
new house where we were staying
grocery store without dog one of the
Santos ah the dog were on the person
went in when I had these guys it was in
their twenties and we've had to be 11 or
12 years old it's going to take our dog
from saying it was their dog
so like Billy takes one in the face is
bleeding and I'm like what happened so
Larry was crazy so early remember we've
always getting into something Billy
being so small and my dad and my uncle
small boxes and so you know it was like
we didn't know it was good we did you
know especially Bill you didn't know it
was good for you get out then somebody
would stand up to you we were more
afraid of our mom yeah yeah it's typical
thing growing up in New Orleans somebody
hit you you better hit him back yeah you
better not come home and say you didn't
do it cuz you gonna get it from me
why do I say mom these guys are so big
they could kill us she didn't want to
hear that she's like go fight them yeah
that was Billy so so the whole time we
were kids Billy by far of all seven of
us was the brightest the smartest like
we all thought we were gonna work for
him and I remember you know when you're
kids you have the hope you know you kids
you fight sibling rivalry rivalry you
fight kids poor and stuck in this little
bitty ass house you're gonna argue and
fight not gonna remember Billy all the
time his argument wanted to go go ahead
keep going keep going because when y'all
working for me you know that's how
that's how we viewed that dude that dude
was like and then after the drugs for a
while and he started to start a little
bit but I think it's because he od'd a
couple times and it made him different I
made a mistake I wish I'd never told him
that but I told him one day I was like
I'm gonna tell him I feel you different
me he goes what do you mean I'm like
you're not as sharp as you used to be
and so I tried to explain it to him
because I thought I was helping him by
saying hey you're brainy
yeah but I think all I did was hurt his
feelings because any time I'd see math
today I'd be like I look I look high now
I was like now Billy seemed I seem sharp
now like yeah sharp and crazy man
addiction that stuff's crazy man I
struggle with it it's struggle you know
it affects a lot of my family and yeah
man yeah Billy you know almost he said
to me one time that him being a
homosexual he said he felt like an order
for him to stop don't address that being
homosexual Wow City because he explained
to me like this one day let's just think
of like a rock star you know you play in
ac/dc all the most when you're it's the
party scene your party they got in drugs
it was just all part of the theme
because I feel like that about being
homosexual it's part of the scene apart
hang out with these dudes we cut up and
so he told me he kind of remember as a
young kid and I thought I saw like I can
remember seeing like a penis owner who
was there but I can remember that and he
was like so he faints that he said he
just thinks somebody sensitized temped
oranges when he was a young age to my
did some torment he don't know he just
knows that it felt good Wow the night
that he looked at it as a bad thing
right yes my brother I can ask him
anything
yeah yeah I just asked him why are you
gay he said you know I'm not embarrass
me I'm not ashamed of it he said would
Wow he said only because of the simple
fact because of society should care
about what society thinks of how they
are but you know we tried to be a little
bit easier yeah if you just said that
one time I don't know if it was high
when he said it but I make sense when
Billy came out to me he told me so on
the same little brother that Billy got
the bikes and hit the store anymore we
in our early twenties and I'm talking we
call our little brother call him sweet
pea and I'm like sweet who's gay
and he was like I'm like somebody in the
family that's really cool
so this dude is getting everybody gimme
everybody we know and so it was like me
and belly was left looking he goes holy
you and Billy's left he looks at me goes
[ __ ] you was a bearded is the last
wannabe guest:do yeah I think when I
think that goes the first gay dude I
ever met man I think I mean I'm trying
brought dude I remember he took me to
some of the gay clubs in New Orleans a
couple times I'd never been before he's
like brah you gonna [ __ ] in and dude he
the thing he'd love to see was marred
the reaction that I wasn't when I went
to see dudes in there and he would start
dying laughing bruh he loves shocking
people shocking people yes he loved that
[ __ ] dude me always thought everybody
was tryin to [ __ ] him or trying to [ __ ]
somebody bruh he would be like dude brah
do you see the way the manager looked at
you man I think she's trying to [ __ ] you
brah feel so like what dude she just
told me to go through the silverware
he's like nah brah you got a watch he's
like - or he coming to back him like
brah I think the chef is trying to [ __ ]
me brah
and I'm like what it's gonna give me a
call and like you know most of our
remembers you just because you know your
popularity and so my family friend
remembers like Billie would always have
Bo his name was though he had our Shawn
bar he had him he had this do Clint
Britt in love with me but I was like
never never I never would thank you like
[ __ ] Adam they talk in the Billie and
just being around Isaac I've never seen
I was talking about you to my son
one international ban I would say
together maybe not to go we build always
have these Deuteronomy he was Guinea but
everybody else you
it didn't seem that's why it's so funny
a friend of mine this weekend we're like
they're like I think that guy was a
pedophile and I said no I said I don't I
mean I think he just kind of never grew
up a little bit but he never tried
anything on me he never liked me I don't
feel like he ever mistreated me or like
was root I think he honestly was just
probably like one of the just one of the
nicer friends that I had and he was also
the tougher he's one of the toughest
friends so it was like you could talk to
him about whatever and then also if [ __ ]
got out of hand he could he could handle
[ __ ] I feel like he's not this big
intimidating figure but you don't worry
about him at all
like I don't these festivals by yourself
he's driving across state and we just we
don't worry about him he's like Chaz
he's gonna land on his feet like a cat
that's how we should feel about done
yeah like I don't ever remember worrying
about it I just didn't worry and even
with the odine and stuff it wasn't like
the girl problem was so bad that he was
on a verge of death this is how the
times I know he's old he's old deed
about four times but four times that I
know if you I was always the same story
so he would stop for a while he'd go
hang out and in the next day dancehall
and that's what happened the last time
so I always say like imagine if you
smoke cigarettes right you smoke a pack
and a half or two packs of cigarettes a
day and then went down cut all the way
down but when you smoke like a cigarette
every other day all cigarette a day yeah
it would be off I'm off I kicked it only
smoke a cigarette again yeah that's how
Billy would be he'd be on all the drugs
is mostly just pills yeah he was always
he always had pills that was it it was
pure like oh no he's been messed with
heroin a little bit at times but that
wasn't really
messy muck was just all the different
pills of methadone yeah
waivers going some clinic and was
getting to help him get off other stuff
so Billy would get the stuff you could
workout buddies I guess one of us game
plan DS and every just go party no party
yeah right and then he he'd get so high
I think he just was hanging out it
wasn't even like there was at a drug
house he was just was hanging out and I
said Billy just gave one looks and
confined he had a bunch of methadone a
bunch of forms and all kind of different
pills I know why Billy bought him I told
you we just got paid he was gonna flip
it you know he's like I'm about us and
I'm gonna oh yeah he always had cash
dude he Billy had cash always and he'd
give you brother he was struggling he
view and he'd give you cash bro you gave
him a ride somewhere he'd give you cash
you know what they thinkin back on it I
think he I think probably some of the
reasons maybe were self-serving why he
you know maybe befriended younger guys I
mean I think sometimes he needed a ride
like he wanted a friend to go work out
with right but he also would pay for the
gym membership so he'd be like hey man I
got us a membership DeFranco you drive
us and I'll do I'll take care of the
membership so you know I think he just
you know he'll I don't know man I'll try
to think sometimes like I mean we were
just friends because we met we were
working at the same place we both like
to work out and then yeah we started
doing steroids so we would [ __ ] you
know I couldn't tell anybody about that
except for him so and then sometimes I
would drive them across the lake to get
weed and it would be like the most weed
I've ever seen in my life bro like
enough to eat where if you were playing
hide-and-go-seek with somebody you could
hide behind it bro that's how much weed
it was when it had a branch like a real
branch from a river with this up one
time
but he uh he always was that he always
was um you know he always treated me
with respect and he always he stood up
for me and he also boosted my feelings a
lot of times when I wasn't feeling good
about myself he would say he would tell
me things about myself that were real
positive things that I couldn't he wants
me he was he he would see things in me
that I couldn't even see in myself and
and I needed that influence in my life
at that time for the right how my mom
was so attached to him too because he
would do the same thing with her I just
would make her feel great when he would
be around yeah yeah he would man he
always complement you he was just so he
was such a loving dude bruh you know and
I never felt like he was loved he was
loving at me and like a gay way I just
always felt like he was just my friend
and then uh and I don't know man I don't
know I'm just it's interesting they were
Hugh and I are sitting here talking
about him years later and we did we
actually sort of went to search we want
to do something nice for your mom we
wanna I don't know if I want to sit down
with there's some time or just next time
I'm at home we want to just take the the
money that was raised and just you know
I know Billy loved his mother he always
talked about his family Brian so we just
we want to do something nice you don't
have to let her know but we will just
playing it as it gets a little closer
when I'm gonna be around home and you
know and you don't have to of course and
ya know we want to though I think he
would want to he wasn't - he wasn't dawn
- she's got the same problems - dicta to
the prescription pills and gets us on
the dock I don't even know it's 40 or 50
pills a month from the doom and if she
runs all about a 15 that a month is
supposed to last all month right now 15
a month she's out and she was talking
trying because she what she didn't have
to kill so she's manic in alcohol and
she's already a manic depressant that's
just bull you know alcohol is a
depressant so it was just that on top of
it you got it in the family it runs in
y'all's family man yeah like that little
store that I owned she lived about two
miles away from it so they called me up
one day
God chalk your mom's in a store she's
got my mom's very pride to like she
doesn't if she went to a restaurant and
your finger was enough like if your the
serve and your finger was in her plate
she's not gonna eat the food she's like
she's real private and weird and she's
not a germaphobe but she just likes her
she won't like for nobody knew her
business and to impose on people so for
them the coffee see she's in a store at
a certain type of way even with her with
the pills and everything was very odd
for me but she's at my store right there
like Chuck your mom's in here she has
one shoe on she's half dressed and she's
trying to buy beer what do we do they
like sometimes I call the police and I'm
like no take her keys from her and see
somebody will bring her home like you
just get a customer somewhere you know
I've been having a store been I grew up
where my stores at back ain't you up
there swear we lived the whole life
everywhere in Laplace know in Marrero
[Music]
attorneys bring her home they called
help any like Oh waiting for somebody to
come get it but my mom was early and
took her keys and she agreed that first
witness wanna go yeah so she's back they
wouldn't give her her keys back she's
parked in front of my store she's
sitting on the horn just blowing horn
like five minutes straight like the girl
had work and she's like customers were
coming in what is going on okay Billy
would have died [ __ ] watching
hilarious dude that's so funny but we
can talk about it then maybe maybe you
can just you know maybe you just keep
the money on the side of case there's a
time to do something nice for and you
can just decide whenever that'll be but
it ain't a ton of money or nothing and I
know you're not thinking about it but I
just on it's the light I feel like it's
something nice that everybody that
bought the shirt I feel like you know
they just care about Billy man and so
they I mean it's weird bro people
[ __ ] you know people like him yeah
Billy would watch it my mom's she's here
she's my stepdads Social Security check
3200 square foot house oh okay
and which chickens and fine you know
Billy would rather if you really want to
do something with the my donated son SPC
well may we'll think of something let me
maybe we'll think of something and the
proceeds could go towards dogs or
something
you know that's a great idea man but
I'll keep you posted and kind of maybe I
can consult with you a little bit about
it and we we could make a choice
together something that uh you know that
he wouldn't that he would approve of you
know but I appreciate your time man and
um yeah man I just I don't know your
brother disinfected of people with a lot
of [ __ ] ridiculous I mean he was just
even though he wasn't alive for that
long it seemed like he was just a life
so much you know yeah it's so young man
this bill that's crazy man it's just so
crazy you just went off cousin's house
took some pills was loaded probably went
to the you know did you forget you took
them that's the problem that's what we
think is a little blind he was a lot of
people that had those kind of problems
they it's hard for them to function just
function at life because the drug is
such a big I mean knocked you down right
right it's all it's it defines you when
you do drugs but it didn't define Billy
that's the different if there's all the
people out there like that
I don't know him but the drugs
definitely didn't define it was just
something that he did yeah and
homosexuality was the same way he wasn't
ashamed yeah loved his sexuality but it
didn't define him it wasn't like hey
that's that gay dude
no it really seemed like the straightest
[ __ ] dude I ever knew bro feel we
play flag football Billy was an awesome
athlete I don't know if you knew that
about head football and we you know and
I twenties I love kids and I can't let
the dream go I'm like getting a flag
football team together you play and he's
like yep we ought to have Billy takes
the flags and it puts them in the fern
as a joke you know
right and he would put his sometimes he
would put his hand kind of face it was a
little bit when he put the flag dude
it's so funny cuz I don't leave it I
mean I think of his being gay is like a
side thing but I guess I know he didn't
define him at all
brah and he didn't like it these dudes
that it does define he would always be
like [ __ ] man these guys are some you
know some real Queens he was really just
man he was just one of a [ __ ] kind
bro
he's one of a con man and uh he was dude
I'm just grateful that I know and man
I'm grateful that I had that I got to
know him and I you know and I hope that
I'll see him again someday and and dude
we got to catch up whenever I'm around
yeah what to catch up I'd love to do
well I'd love to be able to do that man
that'd be awesome
oh well I'll be in touch man you got my
number two and if there's something that
I can do you know and I'll keep you
posted we'll figure it out but I think
something maybe with dogs
yeah we'll think of something cool
whatever it's all good man
I'll just appreciate I was told my
brother yesterday it sounds like kind of
wrap it up not to see
right here but uh not so my brother
yesterday's I'm actually mad about this
shirt because I didn't think of it first
you know remember my brother loved the
image it's like that it definitely does
cache image on that shirt he captures
Billy what's funny I told a guy they
said well what did he look like I said
he looked a little bit kind of like don
flamenco from the yeah maybe that's how
I even remember that maybe he told me
that bro I don't know but um yeah man
yeah I'm just I'm grateful that I knew
him and I'm grateful that he existed in
and I'm glad that you have so many I
mean you have so many memories of him
man that's pretty cool bro and you seem
to really understand kind of who he was
he was just man he loved to instigate he
loved to just see people's reactions
he'd love to just he loved to have just
be a part of what was going on you know
yeah he's definitely an inspiration to
me but I'm glad even just hearing you
talk about him reminds me of so many
things that I just forgot about you know
definitely just you know forget about it
but I'm just waiting I wanna I want to
show like I want to show you can you
talk I know it's just gonna touch and
she's gonna cry so it was wait for a day
well spirits a good I think she's ready
to handle it
ya know she's 70 now and yeah a little
tough but she definitely misses him she
still got his ass if she keeps when she
talks to him and so it's like it just
happened still you know just because it
just I don't know it's gotta be real
yeah I can't imagine man I really can't
imagine you know what's funny not think
about it there's so many like I started
just telling stories from growing up and
then people would always write on social
media about Billy and so it was like I
didn't say hey
right about Billy - you know talk about
people would just bring him up all the
time and so it kind of created like this
life of its own a little um yeah I wish
we had some other pictures and stuff of
him but uh but yeah maybe when I come by
do you could show me a couple of uh if
you guys got any old photos that'd be
great to see you have to check it out
yeah for sure yeah any time you do a
show summer I want to come check you out
Mississippi Louisiana close you know
driving distance let me know yeah I will
man just don't bring any of those
[ __ ] dogs brought us it scares me I
just hadn't you know I had so I had
Billy's dogs until they both died and
then a relative of us has a brother
Billy's dogs one of his dogs and so I
got two dogs from that litter yeah and
the last one just died about three
months ago he made all week at his house
with us
Wow yeah yep yeah that Billy conforto
strain or Billy Mintz what name did he
go by me and we I knew him is be like a
quarter but do we would be walking into
a building bra and it would be like hey
if anybody asks in here from Billy Mets
tell him my name is Chad brah that's
what he was said so I never knew who you
check every building we went into he was
a different fight different variation of
its name conforto is my grandmother's
maiden name she came consists of myself
it's her maiden name and my her her
father my great-grandfather had Papa Joe
goes on Bourbon Street was Papa jokin
far though he had the original Papa
Joe's I think there is still a Papa
Joe's I do something on birth mmm-hmm
but early with all his troubles Oh is
why he went back to Florida so as my
grandmother's named Billy actually had
an ID with his picture on it said Billy
can actually was both you know he was
he's a million people in one person man
he really was there's a book the sky
Frenchy let I think his name was he saw
just uh he just recently was murdered in
New Orleans but he wrote a book and I
think it's called
it's a pretty interesting book he talks
about the conforto was my mother and how
brothers there's so many things that
they did in his and it's it's it's just
more stories of like our family I'm like
yeah look you know we tell these stories
and I wonder if people like man how true
me how you know what details was just
changed a little bit that you know that
was but I'm like I just pick up this
book and I'm reading it's called mr. New
Orleans and I'm reading this book and I
see the name conforto and I read this
book is talking about my my uncles Wow
you know and you ever check it out right
look scroll through it pretty quick and
see what he says about the stories you
almost somehow take legs that are a lot
of that's wild I'm telling you do you
guys got a special strand or whatever
DNA y'all got man it's uh there's
something about it you know just with my
name anywhere like everybody's like wait
a minute
my son and all that good stuff and I do
have dim boys man I just was almost like
just in the audience just watching and
being entertained you know to me yeah
it's great
yeah well man I'm just glad that I even
had that I've had the ability to know
y'all's family man I really appreciate
the time dude and tell your son I said
what's up and we'll get around there
whenever I'm back in town
yeah dude hit me up I will man I
appreciate it bro and uh and I will talk
to you soon man r.i.p billy comfortab
[Laughter]
respect man I appreciate that thank you
very much for job for telling me
that and give it a tell them I said
what's up as well I will all right man
I'll talk to you soon man thank you bro
peace man